J J jo hallo in mü ja meine Frage an
dich ist bist du immer so geil drauf
also außerhalb meines Fernsehers und so
oder was ist los ja das ist nee das war
meine Frage es ist eine Mischung ich bin
wenn man mich kennt tagsüber stehe ich
wenn ich z.B im Schanzenviertel in
Hamburg unterwegs bin nicht auf dem
Tisch ich tanze auch tagsüber nicht ich
trinke auch tagsüber nicht und rauche
auch tagsüber nicht wenn allerdings der
Abend über uns zieht dann öffne ich
schon mal eine Flasche Bier oder trinke
sowas dann rauche ich und dann bin ich
werde ich komischerweise auch lauter je
dunkler es wird umso lauter werde ich
das ist übrigens der Titel meiner
nächsten CD das finde ich ganz schön die
Mütze war cool ich will auch mal so
schieemützen und sowas irgendwie tragen
aber andererseits muss man auch sagen
wir haben habenich du hinter der Kamera
ne du hast deinen Namen schon mal gesagt
ja wie war der Thomas
Thomas wenn so ältere Frauen so mit
Mitte 40 unbedingt diese Trends
mitmachen wollen die Jungs oder junge
Mädchen machen das wirkt dann eher
tragisch ne also schiebemützen und so
Gedöns berufsjugendlich berufsjugendlich
ist findet ihr das eher albern das kommt
auf die Person an wenn ich das machen
würde würdest Du es albern finden ich
habe so Hosen die haben so ein Schritt
der hängt in den Knien und so weißt du
so ein bisschen newan mäßig und das
haben wir doch zu unserer Zeit auch
getragen ich kann mich so schwer davon
verabschieden wenn ich ehrlich bin und
ich habe früher selber immer sehr da
drüber geschimpft und habe gesagt lass
doch den Jungs ihre Mode nimm den das
doch nicht weg und ich mag das dann so
gerne leiden aber es ist ein Problem da
hast überhaup keine Ahnung von Christoph
merke ich schon das interessiert dich
auch do do doch pass auf pass auf doch
das Thema das bearbeite ich ich habe ich
sage man muss Trend seten Trends ja aber
das tun ja die jungen Leute mein trenden
dass der ältere sag nein Z das karrierte
Hemd ich bin ein Trendsetter für die
Brille in Kombination mit kariertem Hemd
also ich habe vorgestern in Bildzeitung
gelesen die Nerdbrille ist komplett out
das ist natürlich tragisch weil ich
trage seit 3 Jahren die Nerdbrille und
die waren teuer diese miesen Teile mit
den teuen Gläsern jetzt brauchen wir
neue neue Gläser es ist out was ich bei
mir festgestellt habe kariert liebe ich
eigentlich auch aber mit mein kurzen
Hand se ich jetzt immer aus wie
Baumfäller Guido sobald ich so ein Hemd
anziehe das ist sehr schade das sah mit
langen Haaren toll aus mit kurzen Haaren
nicht mehr so toll bei dir sieht es aber
auch mit kurzen Haaren aus wie
baumfellerkino